Mike thanks for joining us how busy is
the day prior to tonight's telecast uh
it gets a little annoying with all you
guys want to talk about it you know
thank you Mike White is eclectic I'm not
quite as eclectic as you are with the
cooking and you know you get a little
bit of sports a little bit of politics
it's pretty good stuff you got going
there man and all you have is you know
height and weight and 40-yard dash times
the waist benders and all of those great
things hi motors good hips right yeah
you try to come up with a couple new
ones every year but I usually when I
need to do what I sit in on an offensive
line meeting room because amidst all the
f-bombs the offensive line coaches are
the most creative and they talk about
Big Uglies slobberknocker you know
elephants on parade every year I get
stuff from those guys if you could be
the fly on the wall in any draft room
tonight and you could hear it unfiltered
which draft room would you want to be in
where you heard everything going on
unfiltered all night long I would prob
at the good one I would I probably say
no England believe it or not even those
are not the random of a second-round I
just find bill belichick fascinating and
I would love to hear what he had to say
as that first round unfolded and just
unfiltered bills of pain whining you
know that is fascinating okay the key to
the first round is it san diego at three
or dallas at four or another team well I
think San Diego is gonna set the tone
here and they've done a nice job of kind
of keeping people in the dark and they
could go with either offensive tackle
which i think is going to affect weather
could affect whether or not Tennessee
tries to get back up in the top ten they
could go with either offensive tackle or
Jalen Ramsey or even the forest Buckner
so they wanted to trade down and I think
when the quarterback issue became moved
it and they're not able to they're
trying to create a market I
don't think there's going to be a trade
market whoever they take their I really
do believe it's going to set the tone if
Cleveland had the opportunity for Jared
golf with age stated number two uh I
can't answer that question I don't know
what's going on there I you know I I
know a little bit more about Philly and
why they went up to number two and the
bottom line is and I think it's the same
whether you're Cleveland North Philly if
you don't believe there's two franchise
quarterbacks that you would bang the
table for then either in the case of
philly you go get them because you do
believe it or indication Cleveland you
get out of there and you say hey we've
got enough tix now that if we want to
get back into the first round at a
certain point and maybe get a tax and
Lynch or kind of cook we can still do
that and I think you only do that move
if you don't believe they're to
franchise quarterbacks a cop who's going
into a better situation golfer wins well
the situation day 14 quarterback is
better with the ramps because they've
gotta run game and they've got a defense
to look at Matt Ryan and Joe Flacco the
year they were drafted they both started
every year excuse me every game as
rookies and they played pretty well and
the reason was the pressure was off
they've had the football they played
defense they kept them out of tough
situation the second round quarterback
you like the most is who I its kind of
cook and he could go on the first if he
goes in the first I don't have a second
round quarterback and I think the
biggest wild carding the entire draft is
Christian Hackenberg of all of the
quarter banks or of all the players as
far as wild card of all the thousands of
players eligible for this draft
Christian Hackenberg is the biggest wild
part and the reason is that he's got
first-round talent he's got a big arm in
64 he's got everything if you drop what
the first round quarterback looks like
it's Christian Hackenberg however the
tape is so wildly inconsistent you don't
know what to deal with them and then
when you throw in all the intrigue of
you played well as a freshman with Bill
O'Brien did not play well the last two
years got the tar beat out of them by a
poor offensive line you mix all that up
into a bowl and you go
what do you do with them and that's a
conversation I've had with a lot of
teams yeah I wonder if Connor cook ends
up with the Browns you know that they
they get a quarterback but they don't
have to take a user first-round pick so
you got an Ohio guy I don't know if
that'll you know play in with Cleveland
looking at Connor cook what do you think
I don't think whether or not where he's
from plays into it i do think what plays
into his leather Cleveland or Philly or
any of those towns where it can be a
little bit tough you know Cleveland
frustrated frustrated and they should be
it's more the mental makeup of a kid
left the physical skill set it can you
handle it can you hang in there when
people are screaming and yelling at you
and wondering either why you're not
playing or why you're playing so poorly
can the kid hang in there and continue
to develop and I think part of the
mental makeup of the kid is important
especially when you look at the
quarterback position we ask you this
every year the least risk attached to a
first-round draft pick would be with who
the foot the forest bochner i think is
minimal risk Ezekiel Elliott is minimal
risk and I'm in jail and Randy's now now
let's go guys are all as clean as it
gets is Ezekiel Elliott worthy of the
number four pick overall yeah as long as
philosophically you're going to commit
and let's say sit the Cowboys did that
two years ago they've got an offensive
line in the fun they had a tail back two
years ago that touched the ball 449
yards and generated 2200 guards of
office and took care of the football and
I think the zekiel Elliott is better
than that tailback so if Dallas takes
him at four and says we're going to be
more than agree you know it's a Dallas
Cowboy Rita we're going back to 14 and
we're going to town a football take the
pressure off Romo i buy into that now
the problem is they better go get some
defensive ends because they don't have
any on the rock I'll leave you with this
is there a way that you can mention Joey
Bosa and not mention JJ watt or Jared
Allen
my bigger problem is gonna be stuck
ollie because that's kind of who you
remind me of one interview so fast times
at ridgemont high Sean Penn oh dude yeah
but Spicoli had a low motor though Mike
in a low motor no oh man he was
relentless Oh out of the classroom mr.
hand and Spicoli wouldn't have passed a
drug test though Mike all I know is we
interviewed both up ethic when he
finished his combine he came up to our
booth and he just had this whole Spicoli
thing going and so as soon as he left I
gonna talk back to our truck and I'm
like hey anybody Spicoli and the whole
truck was like we will Spicoli make an
appearance on the draft coverage tonight
um I don't know I it might be better off
as an exclusive for the Dan Patrick all
right I like that all right fair enough
fair enough right good luck tonight Mike
I know you're busy we always appreciate
your time Thank You Daniel the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience